Muslim
Abul Hussein Muslim
Muslim.
[Silence]
for
Mary.
at im Muslim
Abdul Hussein Muslim,
the great scholar of hadith and the
author of the authentic compilation
known as Sah Muslim.
He narrates a narration on the authority
of one of the companions. His name was
Abdullahn
and he was one of the servants of the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam. He
mentioned that he came once to see the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam while he
was in salah. So he came he found him in
salah and he was reciting the verses
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
human being
that
collecting
and
the race for the dunya and the race
for collecting and the race for
accumulating
wealth and other things of the dunya.
The accumulation. Allah literally says,
what is
the accumulating?
Accumulating has distracted you all
until you wake up and find yourselves
visiting the graveyard. Meaning a person
is so obsessed with collecting, so
obsessed with obtaining, so obsessed
with accumulating
wealth, accumulating power, accumulating
notoriety, accumulating and the person
becomes so obsessed with this that it's
almost as if they are in a stuper. They
are asleep.
And the average human being remains in
this sleep until he visits the cemetery.
Visits the cemetery because that's not
our final place. That's just one of our
steps on our way to Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
Allah tells us you will come to stand
before Allah one stage after another.
And so one of those stages is the
cemetery. A person only really wakes up
when he finds himself 6 feet under.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
was reciting these verses and crying so
deeply trying to restrain himself
that his breath was wheezing a
boiling kettle.
Abdullah described it wheezing a
And afterwards the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam commented on these verses. He
said the human being, the son of Adam,
he is constantly fretting. He's
constantly saying, saying with his
actions, saying with his behavior,
saying with the things he chooses to be
upset about, saying with the things that
occupy his mind, my money, my money, my
property, my things, mine, mine, mine.
And the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam says commenting on this
and oh son of Adam do you really really
get to keep any of your money except
that which you eat and physically
becomes a part of you that which you put
into your body and it goes away or that
which you put on your body and you wear
it out clothing or that which you give
for the sake of Allah and it is there
for you when you meet Allah on the day
of judgment. Three things he mentions.
The only thing that we really keep of
our wealth, everything
that you have that I have, everything is
given to us on lend.
It's it's being borrowed. We're
borrowing it. The only thing we get to
keep really is that which we physically
put into our bodies
or that which we wear on our bodies
until we wear it out or that which we
give for the sake of Allah in the way of
Allah for the path of Allah and we get
to keep it on the day of judgment.
Everything else goes back in the box
a board game.
Just a board game. everything else.
After we fight and we yell and we throw
the dice and we pray and we after all of
that and the winner is declared and the
loser conceds, we fold up the board game
and we put it right back into the box.
That's it. It goes right back into the
earth to be used by the people that come
after us.
All that money you fought over, all that
property, all those things you fredded
over. Well, guess what? When you die,
when I die, when we pass away and we go
to visit the cemetery from the underside
of the earth, someone else gets all that
money for free.
They don't have to work for it. They get
it for free. They didn't shed a tear.
They didn't persspire a drop of sweat,
but they get it all for free. Is that
fair?
Person may say that's not fair. Nobody,
no one compelled you to play that game.
The only thing that is yours is what is
a part of your body or what is
physically on your body or that which
you give to Allah to find on the day of
judgment. only those three.
We ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
grant us the insight to recognize the
truth when we hear it. We ask Allah to
grant us the courage to adhere to that
truth in spite of the consequences. We
ask Allah the nobility of dying for and
upon that truth and the honor of being
resurrected with his people. We ask
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to teach us of
the Quran what we are ignorant of. We
ask him subhanahu wa ta'ala to benefit
us from that which he has taught us. And
we ask him to remind us of the Quran
what we have been made to forget.